la crise sanitaire a poussé bon nombre
de français à remettre en question leur
avenir professionnel certains ont décidé
de changer de voie quand d'autres
s'adaptent à la situation
illustration avec ce reportage de mona
amoudé l'art aurore et florent ont pris
pour habitude de sillonner les salons
dédiés aux agriculteurs de toute la
france comme ici au pari fermier à
vincennes le déclic
ils ont eu à la suite du confinement
après une carrière dans l'aéronautique
un secteur durement touché par la crise
florent est contraint de démissionner
avec sa compagne aurore il décide alors
de lancer un projet intitulé made in
france foot courte
le concept très prisé aux etats-unis au
moyen-orient consiste à proposer
plusieurs comptoirs de restauration
différentes dans une seule salle celui
du couple mettra en avant les
spécialités culinaires des grandes
régions de l'hexagone
le confinement a grandement joué dans la
maturation du projet et nous a confortés
dans nos idées et la volonté donc de le
mettre le mettre en oeuvre avec
notamment les agriculteurs qui ont
extrêmement souffert une volonté des
français d'avoir des circuits courts
d'avoir une traçabilité d'avoir une
juste rémunération de ces mêmes
producteurs et donc ce sont tous ces
enjeux-là qui nous ont confortés dans le
projet et on souhaite avoir un concept
de restauration qui soient à nouveau
pour contribuer au rétablissement de la
restauration à paris le projet d'aurore
et florent se fait conjointement avec
les agriculteurs français de tout le
pays
un métier qui souffre depuis plusieurs
années d'une subtile fils d'agriculteur
petit-fils même de résistante puisqu'il
ya 30 ans mon grand père avait fait le
choix très fort de maintenir une
agriculture biologique résonnaient à ta
vie humaine ne pas prendre le tournant
de la culture extensive et justement
c'est pour moi le moyen de faire vivre
et revivre cette agriculture biologique
qui prend un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui en
france selon la co fondatrice de ce
projet 100% made in france
il faut valoriser les savoir-faire la
production française et favoriser les
approvisionnements nationaux il ya une
vraie volonté de revenir aux sources on
avec le confinement en province que les
click and collect auprès des
agriculteurs se développer que les gens
voulaient
se consommer de plus en plus locale et
avoir une certaine aussi indépendance
culinaire donc je pense que c'est le bon
moment justement de profiter de ce
contexte les français veulent un retour
à la france en fait le projet est aussi
sociale les deux entrepreneurs veulent
être une porte à l'emploi on voudrait
favoriser la perte d'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap et
soutenir la jeunesse qui a parfois des
difficultés pour rentrer dans le monde
de l'emploi pour un premier stage pour
une expérience professionnalisante et à
chaque région sa spécialité il y en aura
pour tous les goûts
l'objectif c'est effectivement d'avoir
un stand un plat par stand qui
représente naturellement le territoire
et ça pourrait être le cas naturellement
avec ce type de produits un projet de
foot courte qui offrira une restauration
française variés éco-responsable et 100%
traçable les gens veulent vraiment
savoir aujourd'hui
d'où vient ma viande ou est-ce qu'elle a
été créée et comment elle a été élevée
on veut donner cette information là à
nos clients selon bruno pelletier
directeur du pari fermier malgré la
crise sanitaire les clients sont au
rendez vous la différence aujourd'hui
après qu vide c'est qu'en fait les gens
s'aperçoivent que nos produits sont à
des tarifs raisonnables et nos clients
ont un besoin c'est de retrouver des
produits sains et produits fermiers
comme on a besoin de travailler
on a considéré qu'il était quand même
important de venir apporter nos produits
selon pro france 92 % des français se
préoccupe de l'origine de leurs aliments
ils recherchent avant tout des produits
bio locaux alors que la fabrication
française est de plus en plus plébiscité
le concept made in france foot cours
pourrait voir le jour d'ici l'été 2021